i've always hated shopping for furniture
grocery shopping they've got cake cheese
and beer sounds perfect to me clothes
shopping sure i'll pick up some new
jeans that's a fine saturday afternoon
but shopping for household items pushing
through the crowds of broke college
students and bickering couples on the
hunt for coffee tables and tv stands all
20-page instruction books a dozen wooden
puzzle pieces and tiny little screws
that disappear into your carpet the
second you take them out of the package
that's my own personal hell so when my
wife brenda the love of my life my light
in the darkest of times asked me to go
to ikea with her to pick up the gloss
dad sofa she found online plus a few
other essentials for the new house i was
reluctant to say the least but love one
now and i just couldn't say no to those
eyes or the promise that we'd pick up my
favorite take out on the way home it
would be a quick trip we run in we grab
the sofa and maybe a highless shelving
unit for her office and we head back out
one hour tops well some mad god of chaos
and cheap furniture must have turned his
hateful eye on me i've been walking for
hours and nothing has changed i knew
ikea was big but this seems impossible
it's like the store never ends i kept
calling out her name brenda but there's
no response just my own voice bouncing
off the flat white surface and rows of
musk and wardrobes i was such a jerk i
always do that get swept up in the
stress when we go furniture shopping i
told myself i wouldn't do it this time
but like clockwork i got overwhelmed by
the vast isles the myriad of options and
the hard to pronounce names i was
impatient i told her to go look at throw
pillows on her own because i was sick of
getting sidetracked she loved throw
pillows no no i i can't let myself do
that it hasn't been that long she's
gotta be here somewhere i can't let the
last time we spoke be a fight about
living room decor day two so it's my
second day lost in ikea i can't believe
i just wrote that also i'm not entirely
sure how many days it's been
there's no windows here i i can't see
when the sun's up and when it's down the
lights turn off sometimes and i think
that's meant to indicate night but i
really can't be sure the clock on my
phone is stuck at 3 22 pm the exact time
we entered the store i guess i should
say i've slept once since being here
managed to camp out on a jizzheim futon
mattress it wasn't the most comfortable
but i've definitely had worse this place
reminds me of the island of the lotus
eaters in the odyssey i can't tell how
much time is passing days and nights
don't really exist here speaking of
eating i wish i had some food right
about now brenda always has granola bars
in her purse and she's ready for
anything i've always admired that about
her had a piece of gum in my pocket but
i think it lost its flavor ages ago
nothing to eat no one to talk to i
haven't seen an employee
another customer not a single living
soul i don't have any signal but my
phone still has battery and my step
counter app says i've walked 30 miles 30
miles still not one friendly face no
exit sign i just had the most horrible
thought as i sit here on this pile of
stones and scribbling in this notebook
what if i'm dead what if i died on the
store floor keeled over from a heart
attack or a stroke or something and this
is my eternal resting place
i know i wasn't perfect i could have
done more charity work volunteered at
soup kitchens and helped more old ladies
cross the street but i didn't think i'd
wind up in hell the philosopher
jean-paul satrey once wrote hell is
other people but i'd like to
respectfully disagree with monsieur
satre hell is an endless vacant ikea day
three so it turns out i'm not alone here
not exactly i still haven't seen another
human being but i did see something else
while i was trying to sleep nestled in a
makeshift bed of sharder cushion covers
and kept awake by the gnawing growl of
my empty stomach i heard a shuffling
sound several feet away footsteps i sat
up eyes darting around for the source of
the sound could be brenda or some other
hapless soul sucked into this prison
with me i spotted the silhouette of a
person wearing an ikea employee uniform
that unmistakable bright yellow shirt a
beacon of hope then it turned around and
i realized this was no ordinary
salesperson their face was smooth
featureless like an egg if an egg was a
size of a human head and perched on top
of a seven foot frame once i noticed its
face or lack thereof i took in the rest
of the creature's nightmarish form
its proportions were all off short
stubby legs beneath a distended torso
that stretched into long long arms that
dragged along the ground as it walked
its hands were massive with tapered
fingers perfect for grabbing anyone who
gets too close well there was no way in
hell i was falling asleep with that
thing roaming around so i got moving and
i tried to sneak my way past it i
thought it was clear when suddenly
excuse me sir
a voice came from the direction of the
monster even though it had no mouth to
speak with
the store is closed
you need to vacate the premises
it spoke in a pleasant tone polite a
true customer service voice but when i
turned it was ripping its way through
the maze of furniture toward me like it
wanted to tear me limb from limb
i i haven't done much running since my
high school track and field days but i
turned and booked it as fast as i could
it didn't matter that it was dark didn't
matter that i could trip at any second
and land face first on a lamp or a sharp
corner of a table i had to get as far
away from that thing as possible before
i found out firsthand what exactly it
did to trespassers but my stamina isn't
what it used to be and i could feel
exhaustion catching up to me i could
hear the thundering of the creature's
footsteps as it gave chase and i knew my
heart couldn't keep this up much longer
so i did what i used to do when i was a
kid and the big neighbor boys tried to
beat the crap out of me on my walk home
i hid i yanked open the doors to a
wardrobe and i stuffed myself in holding
the doors closed from the inside i could
hear a scrabbling sound against the door
the scraping and scratching of the staff
monster trying to get at me through the
wood but thank the swedes for their fine
engineering because that wood just would
not give after what felt like an
eternity the assault on the door stopped
and i could hear the creature shuffling
away off to another section of the
massive store i stayed there in the
pitch dark for a long time slowing my
breathing down and trying to get my
heart to climb back down from my throat
what was that thing did it live here
where did its voice come from how did it
know i was here the questions bounced
around my mind and i knew i might never
find the answers i'd guessed before that
this was no ordinary ikea the endless
rows of aisles and total lack of any
human beings had been a pretty good clue
but now i knew for sure i had left my
own world behind as i drifted off to
sleep the wardrobe closing around me
like a coffin my drifting consciousness
thoughts were of brenda whether she was
trapped in here too and on the off
chance she was if those creatures would
get to her before i could after the
lights turned back on and the new day
began i started my walk in search of one
thing only
food i'd felt the hunger getting to me
before but after my sprint away from the
faceless monster my body was nearly limp
with exhaustion i had to get some
calories in me as soon as possible or i
might not have the strength to run for
my life next time it took a few hours of
walking but i eventually spotted what i
was looking for there's only one thing
i've ever enjoyed about ikea and it's
those beautiful little meatballs as i
rounded a corner past a stack of vans
delaying plant stands the heavenly aroma
hit me like the most welcomed slap to
the face in the world there in front of
me bathed in the warm glow of the
fluorescent lights was the store
restaurant and in the center a trough of
meatballs i could see the steam rising
up from the little jewels of meat i
didn't care there was no chef present or
anyone who could have made them i ran to
the food and i stuffed my face once my
stomach was full of meatballs and my
heart full of new hope i examined my
surroundings there were snacks swedish
snacks i could bring with me i grabbed a
clamby canvas bag and began to fill it
with whatever i could grab cans of cider
jars of lingonberry jam and mustard
boxes of muesli and bags of sour candy
hell i even grabbed some of the salty
licorice when food is this scarce you
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
even when its breath absolutely reeks
i'm not too sure where i'll sleep
tonight don't want to be out in the open
in case more of the staff find me i try
not to think too long about what might
happen if they catch me next time maybe
this is crazy but i think i'll build a
fort i've got plenty of space for it and
plenty of materials i'll climb up to the
top of a tall shelf and build a fort up
there just have to hope i don't toss and
turn too much of my sleep or i might
impale myself on the tadag floor lamp
day four something incredible happened i
built my fort pretty close to the food
area so i'd be able to access it again
when i woke up when the lights came on
this morning i saw someone helping
themselves to the meatballs they
couldn't be staffed because they've got
nowhere to put the food even if they did
i took a closer look and it was a person
an actual human person blonde woman in a
blue sweater loading up a bag with
meatballs and other supplies just like i
had the previous day hey called out to
her and my voice felt strange rusty from
not talking to anyone for days i guess
she spun around brandishing a fire axe
right she probably thought i was staff
member preparing to attack i waved my
arms to draw attention to my face its
eyes nose and mouth to make it clear i
wasn't one of them sorry sorry i i'm
human hello her posture relaxed and she
motioned for me to come down and speak
to her she introduced herself as gloria
and explained that she was part of a
community of other humans who had built
a town in the checkout department they
had set up lights beds and most
importantly a gate to keep the staff out
at night how long have you been here she
asked me as we made our way towards
checkouts together um four days i think
her eyes widened impressed most people
usually don't make it through that many
nights alone in here the staff gets to
them first i shuddered at her words my
thoughts turned once again to brenda i
asked gloria if she'd seen my wife at
all if she'd made it to the checkouts
before me she shook her head sadly i
came in with my sister she told me i
haven't seen her since and how long have
you been in here i asked gloria's side
and patted me on the back before
speaking again about a year we were
silent the rest of the walk and by the
time we reached the gates of checkouts
the lights were turning off for the
night quick we need to get inside gloria
ushered me through the gates and
followed behind i was about to question
her urgency when suddenly two faceless
horrors lurched from the shadows these
two staff members were smaller than the
ones i'd seen before maybe four feet
tall they had the same long arms though
and they were reaching for us as they
ran at the gate with primal speed they
threw their bodies against it arms
stretched towards me and gloria i
screamed jumping back gloria just
watched them stone-faced waiting to see
if this would be the night they actually
broke through after a while the staff
gave up and stumbled away and i turned
to take in the town of checkouts i never
thought i'd be so thrilled to see a
collection of beds lamps and strangers
so many people when i had worried i'd
never seen another person again there
are around 40 people in total though i
haven't met everyone yet some folks were
already sleeping when i got there or
keeping to themselves the people i did
meet nearly knocked me out with their
kindness they fed me gave me water a bed
to sleep in and a set of clean clothes
one of them had fashioned out of sheets
they're not exactly stylish but i'd take
anything over the t-shirt and slacks i'd
been sleeping and sweating in for days i
think i could be okay here at least for
a little while at the very least i'll
get a good night's sleep for once day
11. so i've been here at the checkouts
for about a week now and as bizarre as
it feels to say this i think i'm
starting to settle in being around other
people keeps me sane without that
endless stretch of silence there's less
space for my mind to wander to the worst
possibilities john one of the men here
had a phone charger with him and i was
able to get mine juiced up again there's
still no signal but i had a few movies
saved and plenty of podcasts i've been
listening to a true crime show with some
of the other people here distracting
ourselves from our own horror with the
tale of somebody else's we gather around
break into the rations we gather during
the day and even crack open some of the
cider while we listen to the silky voice
narrator to take us through the story of
bloody murder in a small town it's kind
of like summer camp you know without the
nature or the camp counselors or the
possibility of it ever ending i've been
asking around about brenda describing
her seeing if anyone spotted her dead or
alive no one has gloria said that maybe
brenda never made it to where we are
maybe she found the exit a long time ago
and she's somewhere in the real world
waiting for me to come back that's what
she thinks happened to her sister it's
coming up on the one year anniversary of
her getting trapped inside and she told
me a secret she's planning to try and
escape she spotted exit signs before and
tracked them across the store they
seemed to move around though shifting
from one place to another when no one is
watching but she's figured out a pattern
and she's going to put it to the test
she's leaving next week she wanted to
tell me she's a nice lady i hope she
makes it day 18. i woke up to the sounds
of screaming i rushed to the gate to see
what was going on and i saw john walking
back from his supply run cradling
something in his arms i couldn't make it
out but it was limp pale and dripping
red as he got closer i saw a head of
blonde hair and my stomach dropped
gloria she had snuck out while everyone
was asleep didn't want to say goodbyes
and tried to find her way out the staff
had found her first she was dead by the
time jon spotted her lying on the ground
a crimson smear across the tile
signaling where the staff had dragged
her they packed her up into a box as a
kind of burial we all said a few words
and then two of the men took the box
away they had to put it somewhere far
from the town before it started to smell
i i can't sleep i can't stop thinking
about gloria and what happened to her
she seemed so
sure so confident i've been looking
through her things which she had left by
her bed there isn't much but there's a
notebook like mine she wrote her plan in
here everything she noticed about the
exit signs the staff's behavioral
patterns i know it didn't work out for
her but there's something here no one's
spotted brenda yet i don't think she's
in here with me i think somehow she got
free she's out there waiting for me i i
can't spend one more night here i won't
i'm gonna go for it i'm finding the exit
tonight whether that's the door out of
this place or the sweet release of death
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
either way i'll be out of this
scandinavian modernist hell hole once
and for all now go check out scp-3008
trapped in ikea and how to actually beat
scp-3008 the infinite ikea for more on
the deadliest furniture store around